the jurgen experience
you know anything brett weinstein said
that was really interesting about this
is it brett or eric i always think brett
and eric there's brothers they're
brothers they both have been on my
podcast
eric is a mathematician who works for
peter thiel yeah i like that brett is
the professor from um
evergreen college that got the day of
absence where they made him
quit because there was they were saying
white people need to stay home
everybody's like that's so racist he's
also a jew
like the jews so he's super super super
progressive it doesn't matter the jews
didn't exactly have it
easy what he was saying that's
interesting he was saying that um
this is not just about that
it's also about subordination and that
you're seeing this subordination
play that's planning that's taking place
and that a lot of these men
like the way they're behaving they're
behaving to be subordinate they're
they're
they're being obedience trained yeah you
know and they're they're giving into it
to show
that you shouldn't punish me because i'm
on your side because they're
they're terrified of the women that are
wielding this power now but i gotta
figure it out building it wildly i got a
theory about that
what's up well men historically when you
create
a bunch of quiet resentment it turns
into loud violence
men are really good at you got to be
careful about
make emasculating men wholesale
because i always worry that it's very
easy to whip them up
when you got the right circumstances in
the right leader and
men like to organize and they like to
fight
and they like to fight back and that's
what makes them feel significant when
they've been emasculated
and i don't think it's you know that's
that expression punishment doesn't
change behavior
it just suppresses it well do you know
that in the turn of the century
um not this one but the last there was a
giant
bachelor culture in america
where men just didn't they had just
gotten through
like a lot of it was like in the 20s too
like and after the depression
it was like the burden of having a
family was just too much
it wasn't attractive to them and there
was a bunch of men that gravitated
towards pool halls
and in nineteen the early 1900s in new
york city
there was more than 900 pool halls in
new york city
damn just stop and think of that damn
more than 900 pools and there's all
these men that would just go there and
they would hang out and they were like
[ __ ] that life and they just didn't want
to have a part of it because it was too
brutal it was too hard
there all this country would need for
this thing to flip on its
[ __ ] ass all they would need is
legalize prostitution
and guys would be like wait hold up oh
wait a minute hold on hold on
i definitely love you i definitely love
you but wait a minute what am i signing
what is this if if people found out that
they could just get sex
any time they wanted if they had a
hundred dollars like if you have a
hundred dollars you can get sex
and you get sex with a pretty girl and
it's clean you don't have to worry about
it
people would be outraged like well how
am i going to have power over this man
if i can't control his sex i could only
i only have him locked otherwise we're
just friends
see if we're just friends i can't have
half his money i can't tell him what to
do
i can't tell him when to be home but let
me ask you a question we have to live
together
yeah and i have to control his sex if we
live together and then i control his sex
then i have all this power but if they
were in a situation where legalized
prostitution was just like
grocery stores was just everywhere what
what would the first of all the amount
of hoes
would probably be the same it's like
they just be a lot richer
now they're just doing it like under the
table it's hard to get away with it they
can get raided
there's sneakiness there's all this you
know they have to they
gold diggers instead of hoes some girls
would just go straight into hoenn
yeah but here's my question do you think
men are more interested
in sex or admiration there's both they
want to be they get fake
admiration from the hose yeah but they
say
they know it's fake though like i think
men i think men
want to be admired more than anything
else they do yeah they do they want
their dick to be the biggest
even if it's a mushroom cap just make
all the noise please and let me know i'm
king kong and that's why and you stick
to the woman a lot of times you'll stick
to that one woman
who you know has got your back no matter
what she's sure
but you're talking about a guy who finds
that there's a lot of people out there
that don't find that for them legalize
prostitution right next to bolero
hop on in get your dick socks right next
to them
sandwich and a dick suck get a grilled
cheese and tomato soup
get your dick sucked like it would
change
like what people need like why
why are you dating are you dating
specifically for sex
or are you dating because you want
companionship like are you too consumed
with work
and are you busy all day and you just
like to hang out with your friends but
you get horny yeah because we have a
solution for you
yeah and if that that was the case i'm
not saying that relationships wouldn't
be the same
but what i'm saying is there's a lot of
relationships that wouldn't be the same
dude i i think you're on to something my
buddy you know stevie blue eyes
she was like he would have stayed in
jail if he had access to women because
he was hanging out with all his friends
he was like it was the [ __ ] best yeah
it was the best because all we do is
[ __ ] around laugh all day lift weights
and you know you just the food kind of
sucks but you're all laughing and you're
all in a shitty situation so everybody
gets along
because if i had girls if i had access
to women i would not have left
that's hilarious this is in fort dix too
like you know the biggest federal
penitentiary in the
world i'm obviously torn on prostitution
because i don't want anybody
that i knows kids or my kids to go into
prostitution
but i also don't think anybody should
tell people
that something that's completely legal
to do for free yeah is illegal to charge
money for
yeah like there is some gay male escort
that came out today
uh there was i put it on my twitter
about like just let these [ __ ] people
have sex like some gay male escort was
talking about the priests
at the vatican and he's like naming
names i [ __ ] that guy i [ __ ] him i
[ __ ] him
he wants to suck my dick i [ __ ] and
you know
they were talking about them being
hypocritical like yeah they're they're
definitely hypocritical
let these [ __ ] people have sex this
is crazy like your system doesn't work
yeah if they just let them have sex
and let them have male escorts just
leave them alone
saying that's fine just as long as you
do you believe in jesus still yeah it's
like dick
i believe in jesus but i love dick okay
well jesus must have put that love for
dick in you
jesus put that love for you that is the
truth sure right
must have yeah and the truth is
it's a complicated thing right because
then where do you so so like
we have these urges and a lot of them
are not very
productive right so you want to have sex
with all
you know you want to have sex with
everybody you can or whatever it might
be but you know that's not
viable because there are just certain
trade-offs to that
well you know the the viable alternative
is
ex-machina you have these uh ai
robot [ __ ] dolls that live in your house
but the problem is they probably get
too smart and they kill your real wife
you know
the algorithm yeah and they figure out a
way to convert your sperm into babies
they just they've
figured out a way to create an actual
digital woman good idea for a movie dude
well it's ex machina that movie did you
see that no oh my god it's one of my
all-time favorites really yeah one of my
top top 20 all-time favorite movies
i'm obsessed with black mirror it's it's
basically an hour and 45-minute black
mirror
wow x-machine is amazing yeah i do love
black mirror it's awesome
but x market is actually even more
intense it's a really well done movie
about ai
and uh it's it has very few cut the [ __ ]
scenes like when you're when you're
watching it you're like whoa
like all of this could be possible yeah